today is june six then you're watching
gamespot news I'm your host Chris waters
and here are this week's top stories did
you want to go I'm you can it's mine
there you go you could okay okay the
witcher 3 wild hunt news bomb this week
gave me those oh so Heights jitters that
i usually associate with like III press
conferences but CD Projekt RED revealed
the release date and this sick is hell
trailer now set for release on
february2014 the witcher 3 is headed for
pc xbox one and ps4 if you fancy
spending a bit more than the normal
asking price you can get all kinds of
schwag and show your support for the
slaughter of magical indigenous wildlife
the trailers packed with all sorts of
awesomeness from the beautiful deadly
and sexy world of the witcher and
gamespot zone kevin van or even did a
trailer breakdown on the characters and
the lore it features that franchise is
so awesome even President Obama was
talking about it this week now if you'll
excuse me I need to go sit down
cross-legged in meditation mode and calm
down my Witcher hype to manageable
levels so jess if you don't die if you
just cool no worries Chris take a minute
what so horizon 2 has been confirmed to
run at 1080p and 30 frames per second
which is apparently just what they were
after while creative director Ryan
Fulton said that the visual fidelity of
1080p was extremely important as a
next-gen benchmark he reaffirmed at 30
frames per second was the best choice to
carry on from 2012 splits a horizon he
explains I think what we did on horizon
was demonstrate that and this is really
important I love framerate that's
absolutely solid and never drops is the
most important thing for our game 30
frames per second actually enables us to
realize that experience the game is also
promising a killer soundtrack deliver
through double the radio station so
you'll have no trouble finding the
perfect track to go along with your mad
driving skills or possibly just constant
crashing in a tendency to drive the
wrong way if I'm the one that happens to
be playing
I always knew Australia was full of
deadly creatures that tried to kill you
I just didn't know jess was one of them
that's mildly alarming next up we've got
some news on a game that's sure to be
featured prominently at next week's III
it's uncharted for some shuffling at
developer Naughty Dog has put the two
leads from the last of us in charge of
uncharted 4 after the departure of
director Amy Hennig Neil druckmann and
Bruce Straley are now co-directing
Nathan Drake's latest adventure the two
are no strangers to the franchise having
played important roles in the
development of uncharted two among
thieves which was absolutely freaking
amazing as for the future of the last of
us it's coming to playstation 4 sometime
soon with no word on any possible
sequels though naughty dog does claim to
have to quote brand new experiences in
the works and now jess is getting very
impatient I need to I gotta go and this
is something that sits little deadly as
a main mobile combat 10 is coming
ethical the violent e.fern breaking
educating madness that we've come to
expect the game is going to land on
microsoft and sony's cars and last
generation consoles as well as PC and if
the suite recently released trailer is
anything to go by then Warner Brothers
promise that this will be the most
brutal combat experience ever may not
just be all talk the developer also
promising all new gameplay and a
cinematic presentation if you can
decipher those wildly big phrases and
more power to you you'll also be able to
choose from multiple character
variations so you can earn your tactical
and careful approach to brutal
dismemberment and senseless violence
lovely super gross Jess thanks ever so
much good news for nefarious villains
this week as they get a stay of
execution Batman Arkham Knight has been
delayed to 2015 the much-anticipated
third arkham game by developer
Rocksteady Studios was originally slated
to release this fall the game is headed
to xbox one ps4 and PC only which will
allow for a Gotham City that is
currently according to rock steady five
times bigger than that in batman arkham
city a lot of folks in our comments
section seem happy with the news
apparently eager to see some games that
really justify that leap to next-gen
sold which are now actually current-gen
consoles in half in for quite some time
super on point this guy Jess do you want
to do some topping now this week on site
do yourself a favor and check out kevin
van all its appearance on Skyrim mods
Danny covers you off on the e3 rumor
mill and the gist takes a look at the
very best of ps4 games and that'll about
do it for the top five news stories of
this week I think we managed to get
through that one pretty well yes good
job yeah I mean we go through it
eventually out so you guys know next
week during 8th grade we will be back
with news every single day usual time
will also have live news check-ins news
breakdowns and stories probably as well
the riding one yeah well reading looking
at them in video format and you'll be on
the live show with Danny and Cameron
Shaw being this articulate it's gonna be
great okay it's III all week next week
folks tons of content we'll see you back
here at gamespot thanks for watching the
news I'm Chris waters your news host I'm
Jessica you're also
I guess water and here my week's top
stories please gonna watch mm-hmm
watches the tones to super gross Jess
thanks ever so much